Die Bergtour auf den Eiger
ist nichts für schwache Nerven.
Links und rechts geht es
mehrere Tausend Meter in die Tiefe.
Bei mir löst dies Faszination
und zugleich Respekt aus.
Der Grat ist hier definitiv schmal.
Offensichtlich und wortwörtlich.
Zwischen Glück und Unglück.
Laura, meine Bergführerin, nimmt mich
auf den weltberühmten Eiger mit.
Nur keine Panik.
- Nein, nein.
Die Erstbesteigung des Eiger
über den Mittellegigrat
ist genau 100 Jahre her.
Eine solche Bergtour bleibt immer
mit einem Risiko verbunden.
Und im absoluten Worst Case, wenn ich
doch Richtung Grindelwald ...
Dann würde ich
Richtung Eismeer springen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Guten Morgen.
Es ist jetzt kurz vor 4 Uhr.
3.55 Uhr.
Die Familie schläft natürlich noch.
Ich muss ein bisschen leise reden.
Für mich geht es jetzt los
Richtung Grindelwald,
wo ich mit Laura Bomio,
meiner Bergführerin,
in den nächsten paar Tagen versuche,
auf den weltberühmten Eiger
zu steigen.
Es ist im Moment
eine ziemlich angespannte Sache.
Aber nicht mal wegen der Bergtour
selbst, sondern wegen des Wetters.
Es ist so unbeständig. Ich habe es
mir gerade nochmals angesehen.
Wir haben unzählige Male überlegt,
ob wir es wagen sollen oder nicht.
Es kann gut werden, aber es kann
genauso gut in die Hose gehen.
Darum bleibt das im Moment
sicher ein spannender Faktor.
Es regnete viel und in
den höheren Lagen schneite es auch.
Das Wetter soll aber besser werden -
hoffentlich rechtzeitig.
Ich mache mich mal auf den Weg.
* Popmusik *
Mein Abenteuer beginnt genau hier.
Ich fahre mit dem Fahrrad
von Zürich nach Grindelwald.
Seit ein paar Jahren
ist das ein Spleen von mir,
dass meine Bergabenteuer so starten.
160 km in gut 8 Std.
Auf geht's! Juhu!
Das gibt mir Zeit, über
die bevorstehende Tour nachzudenken.
* Popmusik *
Der Brünigpass.
Letztes Jahr
stieg ich aufs Matterhorn.
Schon das war eine Herausforderung.
Mir wurde aber gesagt,
dass diese Tour über den
Mittellegigrat schwieriger sein soll.
Davor habe ich Respekt.
Ich bin aber auch gespannt,
was mich dort oben erwartet.
Dort - das Ziel vor Augen: der Eiger.
Die Nordwand
liegt gerade ziemlich im Nebel.
Jetzt hoffen wir, dass sich der Nebel
möglichst bald lichtet.
Dann kann es losgehen.
Am nächsten Tag.
Es ist Ende August.
Jetzt
geht die zweitägige Bergtour los.
Ich gehe natürlich nicht allein.
Hinter mir ist Senfi mit der Kamera -
ein guter Freund und für die nächsten
beiden Tage auch mein Kameramann.
Oberhalb der Kleinen Scheidegg
treffe ich Laura, meine Bergführerin.
Hallo. Du musst Laura sein.
- Genau. Hallo, Matthias.
Was meinst du zum Wetter?
Wie du gesagt hast:
Im Moment ist es noch bedeckt.
Aber dort
tut sich schon ein Loch auf.
Wir hoffen ...
- Ein Loch für die Optimistischen.
... dass es besser wird.
- Glaubst du, es reisst noch auf?
Ja,
hoffentlich in den höheren Lagen,
also in Richtung Hütte.
Das hier ist schon eine Ecke,
in der der Nebel hängen bleibt.
Ich habe ja dich. Du entscheidest.
- Wir schauen mal.
Gut, gut. Auf geht's!
Voilà!
Danke schön.
- Bitte schön.
Hey!
- Hallo, du Süsse!
Ich habe es schon erlebt,
dass Leute sagten,
sie seien
auf dem Matterhorn gewesen.
Dann hatten sie hier aber doch
gewisse Schwierigkeiten.
Man musste ihnen sagen,
dass es vielleicht nicht reicht.
Es ist v.a. klettertechnisch
vielleicht etwas anspruchsvoller.
Und diese Bahn
bringt uns jetzt hinauf?
Jawohl, der Eiger,
zur Station Eismeer.
Ab der Station Eigergletscher
geht es mit der Zahnradbahn
durch das Bergmassiv des Eiger
bis zur Haltestelle Eismeer
auf 3'160 m ü.M.
Ein Seitenstollen
führt zum Gletscher hinaus,
wo die eigentliche Tour beginnt.
Die Route verläuft zuerst
auf dem Gletscher und dann im Felsen
Richtung Nordost zur Mittellegihütte
auf 3'355 m ü.M.
Gut.
- Gut.
Hier steigen die meisten Leute aus,
um auf das Eismeer zu blicken.
Ah, sieh an! Und wir gehen weiter?
Wir fangen hier mit unserer Tour an.
- Endlich!
Cool, ich freue mich.
Ich war mir nicht bewusst,
dass dieser Berg so durchlöchert ist.
Dass er so viele Ausgänge hat?
- So viele Stollen und Querstollen.
Ein Labyrinth.
So!
- Voilà, da sind wir.
Ich bin auf die nächsten zwei Tage
gespannt, aber jetzt geht's los.
Jawohl, packen wir das!
- Das sehen wir dann noch.
Aber wir versuchen es.
- Mhm.
Und wie es losgeht.
Laura hat mich schon vorgewarnt,
dass gleich am Anfang
eine sehr gefährliche Stelle kommt.
Jetzt sind wir an einer Stelle,
an der es wegen des Gletscherbruchs
gerade noch okay ist.
Du siehst dort oben diesen Turm.
- Ja.
Es geht hier geradeaus weiter.
Solange wir unter diesem Bruch sind,
versuchen wir, etwas Gas zu geben.
Ist schon mal was passiert?
- Es kommt immer wieder vor.
Natürlich nicht täglich, aber
es kam in den letzten Jahren vor,
dass jemand darunter stand,
als ein Teil abbrach.
Man geht nicht lange
darunter durch.
Wir versuchen,
es möglichst kurz zu machen.
Es ist einfach
kein idealer Ort hier.
Ist es in den letzten Jahren
schlimmer geworden,
kann man das so sagen?
Nein, soweit ich mich erinnere,
gab es diesen Abbruch
hier beim Zustieg schon immer -
zumindest in den letzten Jahren,
in denen der Grat
so oft begangen wurde.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Das ist jetzt diejenige Zone,
in der du nicht anhalten möchtest.
Nicht unbedingt, nein.
- Gut.
Geht's?
- Ja, es ist gut.
Laura zieht mich drüber.
Hier auch nochmals.
- Jawohl.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Also, Laura, jetzt ist der Puls
etwas hochgegangen.
Ja.
- Oder nur bei mir?
Nein, das fordert jeweils schon.
Man atmet schneller
und der Puls geht
wegen der objektiven Gefahr hoch.
Falls es zu schnell ging:
Ich weiss nicht,
ob man es mit dieser Kamera sieht,
aber das dort sind alles
irgendwelche Gletscherstücke,
die jederzeit
einfach runterfallen könnten.
Wir sind
genau darunter durchgegangen.
Wenn so einer abbricht ...
Ja, dann ist es wohl vorbei, oder?
- Das ist nicht so gut, ja.
Wir gehen noch ein Stück weiter.
- Gut, gehen wir.
Wir stehen hier noch nicht ideal.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Ui!
- Ui, ui, ui!
Zufälligerweise sehe ich,
dass ein gebohrter Haken,
der das Kletterseil sichern sollte,
sich einfach so aus der Wand löst.
Jetzt ist dein Vertrauen
ein bisschen erschüttert.
Na ja, gerade mal so.
Sorry, gebohrte Haken ...
Ich dachte, das sei
Klettergartenstyle, das halte.
Ich habe zugesehen, wie ein gebohrter
Haken am Seil hinunterrutschte.
Ja,
das verstärkt die Devise noch mehr:
nicht stürzen,
gar nicht ins Seil fallen.
Aber ja, das scheint Laura noch nicht
aus dem Konzept zu bringen.
Nein, nein, nur keine Panik.
- Nein, nein.
Von einer Panik
bin ich noch weit entfernt.
Jetzt
gehen wir gemütlich zum Felsen.
Du wirst sehen, es geht tipptopp.
Ich sehe mir das jetzt genau an.
So.
Voilà!
Gut, Matthias, du kannst kommen.
- Gut.
Diese Tour ist für mich
alles andere als ein Spaziergang.
Ich bin konditionell gut in Form,
aber kein geübter Kletterer.
Gut.
Wie gesagt:
Hier ist vom Klettern her
die schwierigste Stelle
unserer ganzen Tour auf den Eiger.
Gut, also, hoffentlich bis bald.
- Jawohl.
Ein grosser Schritt um die Ecke.
Das ist manchmal so ...
... die Krux.
Die Krux.
Scheisse, Mann,
ich sehe sie nicht mal mehr.
There we go.
Da gibt es eine gute Stelle. Uah!
So! Hier ...
Das sind die eleganten Schritte.
Uah!
Bei Laura sah es ziemlich
locker aus. Wie fühlt es sich an?
Verschissen.
Ah, jetzt bin ich zu hoch.
Matthias, geh nicht zu hoch!
Siehst du? Was habe ich gesagt?
- Gut.
Uah!
- Super.
Hineingemurkst.
Genau, klassisch:
Ich bin zu hoch hineingegangen.
Ich wollte wieder zu viel.
Jetzt wurde es ein Gemurkse.
Yes!
- Du bist wie ein Rädchen gekommen.
Das ist doch gut.
- Ein erster Teilerfolg.
Gut.
- Dann gehen wir der Hütte entgegen.
Es gibt hier sogar noch
einen schwachen roten Pfeil.
Hier fängt es an.
Man darf eben nicht zu tief gehen.
Ja.
- Sonst steckt man plötzlich fest.
Aber es gibt meistens mehr
als einen möglichen Weg.
Ja.
Ich gehe einfach dir hinterher.
Du hast eigentlich
auch gar keine andere Wahl.
Die Leine ist kurz.
Schau! Siehst du die Hütte?
Nach gut 2 1/2 Std. Klettern
und Wandern
erreichen wir die Hütte
auf dem Mittellegigrat.
Hey.
- Heja.
Danke.
- Cool, oder?
- Das ist die neue Mittellegihütte.
Tag 1.
- Tag 1.
Kommt jetzt der gemütliche Teil?
- Ja.
Jetzt essen und trinken wir etwas.
Laura wurde letztes Jahr
zur Bergführerin brevetiert -
als erste Grindelwaldnerin. Frauen
sind Exotinnen in diesem Beruf.
Auch ich bin erstmals
mit einer Bergführerin unterwegs.
Der erste Eindruck, wenn ich komme,
ist wohl - und das ist auch normal,
das nehme ich niemandem übel -, dass
sie sich unter einem Bergführer
nicht eine junge,
eher kleine Frau vor.
Aber das
legt sich jeweils sehr schnell.
Ich glaube, am Ende ist es
auch ein gesellschaftliches Ding.
Das Bergsteigen ist für mich
ein Abgleich unserer Gesellschaft.
Und es ist
halt schon noch ziemlich stark
auf Image und Heldentum
ausgerichtet.
Und die Frauen sind schon noch nicht
so ganz in der Mitte des Alltags
angekommen, habe ich das Gefühl.
Es ist 16 Uhr.
Ob wir morgen zum Eiger aufbrechen,
ist nach wie vor ungewiss.
Mit meinen Wettersorgen bin ich
aber offensichtlich nicht allein.
Good morning.
Kommt es oft vor, dass du
den Leuten Auskunft geben musst?
Ja.
- Was sind das für Leute?
Ich denke,
viele Leute wollen einfach,
dass man ihnen
die Entscheidung abnimmt.
Aber was das Wetter betrifft,
muss sich jeder selber informieren.
Ich habe einfach Laura.
- Genau.
Bin ich bei ihr in guten Händen?
Ja, definitiv, ja.
Gut.
Dann gehen wir mal essen.
- Ja, geniesst es.
Schönen Abend.
- Danke.
Et voilà.
Der Blick aus dem Fenster zeigt:
Der Nebel lichtet sich.
* Mystische Musik *
Ich hoffe, ich schaffe es.
Ich wanderte noch nie so exponiert.
Hier links geht es etwa 1'000 m
runter, rechts etwa 1'500 m.
Und ...
Ja, ich überlege gar nicht zu viel.
Ich gehe einfach Laura hinterher.
Aber sieh dir das an!
Hier merkst du, dass du lebst, nicht?
Du bist seit einem Jahr Vater.
- Ja.
Hat das
ein bisschen etwas verändert?
Ganz ehrlich? Nein.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Also, du meinst jetzt
so mit Vorsicht und ...
Ja, solche Sachen.
- Na ja ...
Ist es dir das wert?
Na ja, vielleicht ist es etwas naiv,
aber ...
Ich mache solche Sachen
nur mit Bergführern.
Ich bin kein Alpinist,
der sich zutraut,
das selber zu machen.
Und ich lebe
halt schon in dem Glauben:
Wenn ich mit einem Bergführer gehe,
übergebe ich die Verantwortung
oder die Einschätzung dem Bergführer.
Wenn er sagt:
"Das machen wir, das ist gut,
das ist zu verantworten",
dann gehe ich.
Und ja, ich lebe bisher gut
in diesem Glauben.
Und zu Hause sehen sie es auch so?
Zu Hause erzähle ich jeweils
nicht zu viel von dem, was ich mache.
Erst im Nachhinein. Ich glaube,
das ist eine gute Strategie,
dass wir
gar nicht zu viel darüber reden,
was wie viel und welche Gefahren ...
Ja, sie sehen es dann
jeweils auf den Bildern.
Aber ich glaube,
meine Frau hat schon auch das Gefühl,
dass ich es bis jetzt
immer gut eingeschätzt habe
oder einfach eher auf
der vorsichtigen Seite unterwegs bin.
Der Grat ist hier definitiv schmal.
Offensichtlich und wortwörtlich.
Zwischen Glück und Unglück.
* Sanfter, mystischer Gesang *
Ich liege die halbe Nacht wach.
Die Höhe und die Nervosität
lassen mich nicht gut schlafen.
Um 4 Uhr wird es in der Hütte
langsam lebendig.
Elf Seilschaften machen sich
heute Morgen mit uns auf den Weg
über den Mittellegigrat
Richtung Eiger.
Also, du.
- Also, du.
Gehen wir in Richtung Eiger.
Wie oft bist du
eigentlich schon auf den Eiger?
Ich glaube, mit dir ist es - ich
muss überlegen - das zwölfte Mal.
Und offiziell geführt?
Offiziell geführt
vielleicht das zehnte Mal.
Krass.
- Ja, ja.
Ein alter Hase -
oder eine alte Häsin.
Gut. Dann schauen wir,
wie weit wir ohne Steigeisen kommen.
Glaubst du, es hat viel Schnee?
- Das sehen wir dann.
Irgendwann werden wir sie
sicher anziehen müssen.
Aber jetzt gehen wir mal so weit,
wie es ohne geht.
Der Mittellegigrat ist heutzutage die
meist begangene Route auf den Eiger.
Von der Hütte geht es permanent
über den Ostgrat bis zum Gipfel
auf 3'967 m ü.M.
Der Abstieg führt Richtung Süden
über die beiden Eigerjöcher
bis auf den Gletscher.
Von dort aus geht es um den Mönch
bis zum Jungfraujoch auf 3'454 m ü.M.
* Keuchen *
Ist es anstrengend?
- Ich komme schon ins Schnaufen.
Aber diese Fixseile
machen es schon viel einfacher.
Du kannst dich
mit einer Hand festhalten.
Du musst nur darauf achten,
dass du gut stehst.
Aber mit den Händen ist es
natürlich viel einfacher als früher.
Bei der Erstbesteigung
ging das natürlich nicht.
Viele Jahre danach auch nicht.
Sie haben diese Seile
aber ziemlich früh montiert.
1926 waren sie montiert.
1921 war die Erstbesteigung.
Also sie haben
natürlich schon gemerkt,
wenn sie das weiterhin
mit Gästen machen wollten ...
Dann befestigten sie halt
diese Fixseile.
Aber die Fixseile
sind schon eine Verfälschung.
Klar, aber wenn sie nicht wären,
gäbe es im Sommer
diesen Betrieb hier nicht.
Ja.
Es wären sehr wenige Seilschaften,
die den Eiger besteigen könnten.
Und damals fanden sie,
es sei es wert.
Diese Tour
ist landschaftlich so schön.
Dann brachten sie diese Fixseile an.
Sicher wichtig,
dass es nicht noch mehr werden.
Ja, ja.
Nicht, dass es eine Autobahn wird.
Aber es ist aus der Tradition
so entstanden und ist halt so.
Ich sage nicht Nein.
Jetzt hier am Berg
sage ich nicht Nein.
Kannst du kurz warten, Matthias?
- Jawohl.
Für diejenigen, die sich fragen,
wie das alles gefilmt wird:
Das ist Sandro, der Bergführer,
der den Kameramann im Schlepptau hat:
Senf.
Die beiden machen eigentlich
die doppelte Arbeit.
Sie gehen immer voraus.
Dann sind sie wieder hinter uns
und überholen uns wieder.
Speedy Gonzales.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Da sieht man schon die Sonne.
- Ja.
Du musst gut auf die Füsse achten.
Dort vorne kannst du dich
gut an der Kante festhalten.
Matthias, du kannst kommen.
- Gut, ich komme.
* Triumphale Musik *
Okay, du kannst kommen.
- Gut, ich komme.
Jetzt ziehen wir die Steigeisen an.
- So?
Ja, ja,
es hat doch ziemlich viel Schnee.
Es wird nicht mehr besser.
Oben hat es wohl nicht weniger.
Also ziehen wir die Steigeisen an.
Gut, gut.
Jetzt waren wir voll im Flow.
- Tipptopp.
Für mich ist es ...
- Schön, oder?
Ja.
Laura, wir hatten ganz viele Momente,
in denen wir am kurzen Seil gingen.
Wir sind sonst
ja nirgendwo befestigt.
Es ist wirklich ausgesetzt.
- Genau.
Aber du vertraust mir
in diesem Moment.
Du siehst nicht mal,
was ich hinten mache.
Ja, dann kommt eben diese Verbindung
mit dem Seil zwischen uns ins Spiel.
Und wenn ich einen Fehltritt mache
oder irgendwo einhänge?
Dann würde ich das
so schnell wie möglich unterbinden,
damit du nicht
in die Geschwindigkeit kommst.
Und im absoluten Worst Case, wenn ich
doch Richtung Grindelwald ...
Dann würde ich
Richtung Eismeer springen.
Dann müssten wir das so machen.
- Musstest du das schon mal tun?
Nein, aber es kommt vor.
Kollegen von mir machten das.
Gerade bei einer Stelle,
an der wir vorher waren,
war ich zum Glück
auf der anderen Seite.
Da rutschte mein Gast ab.
Ich musste ihn auch halten,
aber wir waren zum Glück
schon auf beiden Seiten.
Da bist du schon kurz ... Aber du
darfst dir nichts anmerken lassen.
Ihr setzt euch
einem wahnsinnigen Risiko aus.
Mit deinen Entscheidungen,
wo du wie sicherst,
versuchst du, das Ganze
so safe wie möglich zu machen.
Aber in den Bergen
gibt es immer ein Restrisiko.
Aber ich hatte viel mehr Angst,
als wir gestern
unter dem Abbruch hindurchgingen.
Da lag es nicht in unseren Händen.
- Ja. Ich hatte mehr Angst als hier.
Gut.
- Gehen wir weiter?
Gehen wir weiter - wie bisher.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Nein, aber hier ...
Kann ich hier nicht auf den Arsch?
Kannst du schon, ja.
- Denn hier ...
Gut,
jetzt fühle ich mich wieder wohler.
Gut, jawohl.
Du bist wahnsinnig.
So.
Hier ist eine coole Stelle, oder?
Du bist wahnsinnig,
so ohne Sicherung.
Voilà! Jetzt geht es dort nach oben.
Ich habe es mir
nicht anders vorgestellt.
Du kannst einfach darauf achten,
dass das Seil gut kommt.
Über 20 Jahre
scheiterten die Bergsteiger
bei ihren Erstbegehungsversuchen
über den Mittellegigrat immer wieder.
Erst 1921 gelang es drei
Grindelwaldnern und einem Japaner,
die letzte grosse Hürde,
den Grossen Gendarm, zu überwinden.
Grindelwaldner Führer
versuchten sogar ...
Die einen kamen von oben,
die anderen von unten.
Sie konnten einander zurufen,
aber sie schafften es nicht ...
Das ist die Schlüsselstelle, die
erst bei der Erstbesteigung klappte?
Genau. Weisst du,
wie lange sie brauchten? 7 Std.
Für diese Distanz?
Von hier aus, vom Hick,
bis zum Ende der Fixseile.
Und wie lange brauchen wir?
- Wir brauchen vielleicht 45 Min.
Sie hatten eine Stange dabei,
die etwa 5 m lang war.
Ja. Aus Holz?
- Ja.
Eine Holzstange mit drei Zacken,
eine Art Dreibein.
Sie stellten die Stange jeweils an
und fädelten oben das Seil durch.
Derjenige, der den Vorstieg machte,
hatte dann eine Art Toprope.
Ah,
sie konnten sich mit den Seilen ...
Über die Stange.
Sie konnten die Stange fixieren
und halten.
Das Seil ging oben hindurch.
Dann ging einer hinauf,
aber er hatte ja von oben
eine Art Seil.
So haben sie sich hochgekämpft.
Gut.
- Na dann.
Ich sehe dich nicht unbedingt, aber
geh einfach hoch und geniesse es.
Ist gut?
- Verstanden.
Sobald das Seil gestreckt ist,
komme ich einfach.
Jawohl, ja.
- In Eigenregie.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
* Keuchen *
Hey, vorher ...
... war es schon
ziemlich anstrengend.
Wir gingen ...
... den grossen Aufstieg mehr
oder weniger in einem Zug nach oben.
Und ja, da bist du fast ...
Wie hoch ist es? 3'700 m oder so.
Da komme ich schon ins Schnaufen.
Es ist wirklich anstrengend.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Super.
Wir gehen noch diesen Riss rauf.
Hu!
Es ist eine etwas bequeme Frage,
aber gibt es einen Grund,
dass man hier kein Fixseil anbringt?
- Du hast es ja angesprochen:
Diese Fixseile sind umstritten.
- Ja.
Du willst nicht den ganzen Berg
in Fixseile legen.
Damit man hinaufturnen kann.
Dafür gibt es hier ein paar Haken.
- Ja, um zu sichern.
Die letzte Stunde
war schon ziemlich intensiv,
das muss ich zugeben.
- Ja.
Anstrengend und steil, oder?
- Ja, auch vom Klettern her.
Ich finde es schon
einiges schwieriger
als eben auf dem Matterhorn.
Halt auch durch den Schnee,
der liegt.
Gut bei dir?
- Ja.
Bis jetzt schon.
Du musst einfach darauf achten,
dass du breit gehst
und nirgendwo anhängst.
Herrlich!
Genau. Schau, Matthias, jetzt
siehst du dort, wo die Nordwand ...
Diese schwarze ...
- Das sind die Ausstiegsrisse.
Dann kommst du hier
aufs Gipfeleisschneefeld.
Du kommst von links hierher.
Unter uns ist die ganze Nordwand?
- Ja.
So,
jetzt kommt langsam ein Wind auf.
* Triumphale Musik *
Höher geht es nicht mehr, was?
Hey, Matthias, da sind wir.
- Da sind wir?
Der Gipfel des Eiger.
- Hey, ich gratuliere.
Heja. Megagut.
- Vielen Dank. Danke, danke.
Super.
- Yes! Juhu!
Cool gemacht. Mega.
* Triumphale Musik *
Schön, seid ihr hier!
Ich gratuliere.
- Sauber.
Vielen Dank! Danke. Senf.
- Hey.
Die Drehmaschine.
- Ja.
Ich gratuliere.
Vielen Dank.
- Super. Danke dir.
Cool.
- Eine tolle Sache.
Eine tolle Sache.
Gut.
- Sauber. Und jetzt?
Unser Abstieg führt dort runter.
- Dann alles dem Grat entlang.
Dann wieder hinauf.
- Genau.
Das ist noch ein ziemliches Stück.
- Genau. Wir haben knapp Halbzeit.
Noch nicht mal.
- Genau.
Aber es kommt
ein sehr schöner Abschnitt -
hinauf, hinab, hinauf, hinab,
dann nochmals klettern.
Gut, cool.
Die zweite Hälfte unserer Bergtour
ist mental richtig anstrengend.
Im Wissen, dass ich
fast alles wieder aufsteigen muss,
kann ich das Abseilen
nur halb geniessen.
Jetzt ist fertig mit dem Abseilen.
- Ja.
Vom Nördlichen Eigerjoch
geht es über zig Kletterpassagen
und zermürbenden Graten wieder hinauf
bis ins Südliche Eigerjoch,
wo wir den Felsen
endgültig verlassen.
"Der endlose Grat" -
so taufe ich das hier.
Über den langen Gletscher geht es
zurück in Richtung Zivilisation.
Das hier ist schon eine andere Welt.
Juhu!
So, hier sind wir
auf dem Jungfraujoch.
Das ist das Ende der Tour.
Tausend Dank
für diese beiden tollen Tage.
Bravo, Matthias.
- Es war ein super Erlebnis.
Wir hatten etwa 8 Std.
für diese Tour.
Ziemlich genau, ja.
Hütte, Mönchsjoch ...
Es war wirklich
eine schöne Bergtour mit dir.
Für mich war es auch
eine absolute Hammertour.
Es war sicher
der schwierigste Dreitausender,
den ich jemals gemacht habe -
viel schwieriger als das Matterhorn.
Es war ein wahnsinniges Erlebnis.
Vielen Dank. - Danke dir.
Für mich waren es drei Tage voller
Abenteuer, Nervenkitzel und Freiheit.
Beim Wetterpoker hatten wir das Glück
auf unserer Seite,
dessen bin ich mir bewusst.
Für mich ist klar:
Ich nehme dieses Restrisiko
für solche Erlebnisse gerne in Kauf.
Wenn du eine Frage an Laura oder mich
hast, schreib sie in die Kommentare.
Wir freuen uns auf die Fragen
und sind auf das Feedback gespannt.